si vous voulez faire de l'hélicoptère
regardez vous avez un simulateur de Nico
donc là la personne elle est assise
directement ici avec ses lunettes de
réalité augmentée dans un siège qui
franchement dépense un hélicoptère on
vient tout piloter directement ici et on
va s'envoler alors je trouve ça
extrêmement marrant parce que une fois
de plus on vient se projeter pour de
l'apprentissage pour de l'entraînement
pas forcément pour le grand public mais
on peut l'imaginer pour des sessions
d'entraînement pour des pilotes et
futurs pilotes je trouve ça très marrant
de voir comment des technologies à base
de réalité virtuelle peuvent vous
permettre de faire ce genre de choses
voilà faut savoir ça au CMS et ça me
fait extrêmement plaisir de voir de
jolies technologies comme ça